- [Instructor] We have four
triangles depicted here,
and they've told us
that the triangles are not drawn to scale.
And we are asked, "Which two
triangles must be congruent?"
So pause this video
and see if you can work
this out on your own
before we work through this together.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
And it looks like for every one of these,
or actually almost every one of these,
they've given us two angles,
and they've given us a side.
This triangle IJH, they've
only given us two angles.
So what I'd like to do is
if I know two angles of a triangle,
I can figure out the third angle
because the sum of the angles
of a triangle have to
add up to 180 degrees.
And then I can use that information,
maybe with the sides that they give us,
in order to judge which of
these triangles are congruent.
So first of all, what is
going to be the measure
of this angle right over here,
the measure of angle ACB?
Pause the video and try
to think about that.
Well, one way to think about it,
if we call the measure of that angle X,
we know that X plus 36
plus 82 needs to be equals to 180.
I'm just giving their
measures in degrees here.
And so you could say x plus.
Let's see, 36 plus 82 is 118.
Did I do that right?
Six plus two is eight, and
then three plus eight is 11.
Yeah, that's right.
So that's going to equal to 180.
And then if I subtract
118 from both sides,
I'm going to get x is equal
to 180 minus 118 is 62.
So this is x is equal to 62,
or this is a 62 degree angle,
I guess is another way
of thinking about it.
I could put everything in
terms of degrees if you like.
All right, now let's do the same thing
with this one right over here.
Well, this one has an 82 degree angle
and a 62 degree angle just
like this triangle over here.
So we know that the third
angle needs to be 36 degrees.
36 degrees.
Because we know 82 and 62,
if you need to get to
180, it has to be 36.
We just figured that out from
this first triangle over here.
Now, if we look over
here, 36 degrees and 59,
this definitely looks like
it has different angles.
But let's figure out what
this angle would have to be.
So if we call that y degrees, we know.
I'll do it over here.
Y plus 36 plus 59
is equal to 180.
And I'm just thinking in
terms of degrees here.
So y plus.
This is going to be
equal to, what is this?
This is going to be equal
to 95, is equal to 180.
Did I do that right?
Yeah, 80 plus 15, yeah, 95.
And then if I subtract 95 from both sides,
what am I left with?
I'm left with y is equal to 85 degrees.
And so this is going to
be equal to 85 degrees.
And then this last
triangle right over here,
I have an angle that has measured
36, another one that's 59.
So by the same logic,
this one over here has to be 85 degrees.
So let's ask ourselves now
that we've figured out a little bit more
about these triangles, which
of these two must be congruent?
So you might be tempted to look
at these bottom two triangles and say,
"Hey, look, all of their
angles are the same."
You have angle, angle, angle
and angle, angle, angle.
Well, they would be similar.
If you have three angles
that are the same,
you definitely have similar triangles.
But we don't have any length
information for triangle IJH.
You need to know at
least one of the lengths
of one of the sides
in order to even start to
think about congruence.
And so we can't make any
conclusion that IJH and LMK,
triangles IJL and triangles LMK
are congruent to each other.
Now let's look at these
candidates up here.
We know that their
angles are all the same.
And so we could apply angle.
I'll do this in a different color.
Angle-side-angle.
36 degrees, length six, 82 degrees.
So by angle-side-angle,
we know that triangle ABC
is indeed congruent to triangle FDE.